ADE OSHINEYE: OK, excellent,
good morning.
In the immortal words of Kevin
Sorbo, let's bring it.
So my name is Ade Oshineye.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Google+ team.
And I'd like to welcome you to
the very first Google+ session
anybody has ever done
at Google I/O.
And let's begin.
So as you can see, I wear this
leather jacket a lot.
I'm Ade Oshineye, I'm a
developer advocate on Google+.
I'm based in the
London office.
And this.
JULIE FARAGO: And I'm
Julie Farago.
I'm an engineering manager
on Google+.
And I'm based in the
Cambridge office.
And I'm going to talk to you a
bit about all of the places
that you go when you
use Google+.
So many of you, I believe,
use Google+ today.
How many of you actually
used Google+ today?
Awesome, good, fantastic.
And if you use Google+, you're
probably very familiar with
the stream, and have hopefully
been privy to a lot of really
excellent conversations that
happen on the steam.
What we find is that when
conversations start on the
stream that people engage
with them very deeply.
I think you just saw some stats
about how our active
users are spending 12 minutes
a day on the stream.
The comment threads are
rich, people +1 posts,
they reshare them.
There's a lot of engagement
that happens there.
I work on a team that builds
tools for publishers.
And when we saw all of this
incredibly rich engagement on
the stream, one thing that we
wanted to do is help highlight
that engagement and help you,
as publishers and as site
owners, understand it more.
So have any of you
used Ripples?
Awesome.
So if you haven't used Ripples,
I highly recommend
checking it out.
Ripples is a data visualization
tool that our
team built in partnership with
a data visualization team and
research to help you better
understand what happens when
your posts go viral.
So if a URL, if a link from your
site gets shared, if a
post that you create on your +
page gets reshared many, many
times, then you can actually go
and view the ripple effect,
the viral effect, of that
post on Google+.
By using this tool, you
can see who the
key influencers are.
So this post right here is a
post that the PM that I work
with, Rick Borovoy, made about
one of the launches that we
had earlier in the year,
the Share button.
And you can see that after he
posted, he was able to see,
OK, well, it turns out that a
lot of the Google pages helped
his post actually go viral.
So having those connections
helped him
reach a broader audience.
In terms of audience, I think
you were all at the keynote,
but we've just announced that
we have 250 million upgraded
Google+ users.
We're really excited about this
number of users because,
as many of you know, the product
is only a year old.
And if you would have asked me
what I expected a year ago, I
don't think that I would have
thought of this at all.
So we're really excited
about where we are.
And I am particularly excited
about all of you using your
amazing content to engage all
of these users even more.
Another great place where we
go when you use Google+ is
actually onto Google Search.
So before I worked on Google+,
I actually worked on Google
Image Search.
And one of the big things that
I worked on while there, with
a number of other engineers,
was working on getting your
friends' images into Google
Image Search.
And at the same time we
were doing something
similar in web search.
This is back in late
2009, early 2010.
When Google+ started, we found a
much, much better channel to
be able to enable you, as
publishers, to get social
recommendations for your
content on to search.
So today if Ade, for example,
shares a great place that I
should go in San Francisco to
me on Google+, or if he +1's
that place, or if he follows its
+ page, then when I search
for places to go in San
Francisco, or charities to
work with or to volunteer for
in San Francisco, then I can
see his social annotation,
his endorsement,
on that search result.
The reason why we believe that
this is incredibly meaningful,
hopefully you do as well, is
because Google Search is many
people's portal onto the web.
It is the way that
they discover.
And so by taking social
recommendations off of just
the social destination site and
bringing it to places like
Search, we believe it really
dramatically increases
people's ability to
discover the best
content across the web.
And then, one of the great
things about being on Google
Search is, of course, again
that we just announced, we
have 150 million 30-day actives,
and 75 million one
day actives.
So the opportunity to reach
people is overwhelming.
It's wonderful.
But we're not just
on Search, social
annotations also affect Ads.
So earlier this week, I was
actually trying to find a
place to stay near a small
amusement park called Story
Land in New Hampshire.
I don't know if any of you have
been there, but it's a
great place for little kids.
We're heading up there
over July 4 weekend.
And I did a search on Google for
Story Land places to stay
and I actually saw a
social endorsement
from one of my friends.
I didn't look any further.
I went, I booked the hotel, and
that's where we're staying.
What we found is that social
annotations result in a 5% to
10% increase in CTR on Ads.
So the impact there, again,
we believe is quite
marked and very real.
Likewise, not just on Ads, but
my team has also been doing a
fair amount of investigation
into what the
impact is on Search.
And again, we've seen that from
your friends, from close
social ties, there is a marked
impact on CTR when a friend
endorses a search result.
So again, by being on the
stream, by being in Search, by
being in Ads, we believe that
social sharing and social
annotations can be a great
tool for discovery.
Finally, I'm really excited
about this.
I don't know if any of you
guys saw this yesterday.
But my team was working late
nights, long weekends, a
couple all-nighters, to try and
launch recommendations in
the +1 Button.
So as of today, if you're part
of the platform preview group,
you can now hover over a +1
Button on any site and see
recommendations for related,
popular, similar content on
that same site.
What we're trying to do with
this is make +1, and sharing,
and following, all these
different tools that we have,
a discovery tool, not just on
Google but also where it
actually lives, so
on your site.
And one of the big reasons why
we're doing this is because
Google+ plugins get many
billions of impressions a day.
So with those billions of
impressions, we want to
convert that into more traffic
for you, more discovery for
our users, and just a better
experience overall.
And so with that, I'm going to
hand off to Ade who will tell
you about how to get there.
ADE OSHINEYE: Hello.
Can I just check?
Who here in this room
is a member of the
platform preview group?
So about a third of the you.
Great.
So today I'm going to talk to
you about a Google+ platform.
But first, I'd like to introduce
you to my family.
Anybody want to guess which
of those people is me?
Clearly, it's 30-something
years old.
So I'm the baby in this photo
And one of the interesting
things about the job that I do
and my family is that my family
are very, very sharp,
but they're not technical.
So when they heard I had a job
at Google as a developer
advocate, they wanted to know
what exactly does that mean?
And then they asked a question
which my manager sometimes
asks, what exactly
do you do here?
Now my manager is currently
unable to be here through
illness, so I don't have to
explain to him, thankfully.
But with my family, I say I work
on the Google+ platform.
And because they're not
technical, their response is
usually, what's one of those?
And I say, because I'm an
engineer, a platform is a
combination of plugins,
and APIs, and SDKs.
And then they get
more confused.
And I say, OK, OK, I can explain
what a platform is.
Think of it this way.
We're Google and there are lots
of people out who have
got websites, who have got
web applications, native
applications, and they would
like Google to help them solve
hard problems.
They would like Google to do
the heavy lifting that they
can build on top of and then
use that to build better
businesses.
And then they sort of say, wait
a minute, how is this
kind of thing going to work?
And I say, well, think
about it this way.
If we can build tools, plugins,
to help people, we
can actually make a difference
to those developers.
And since you're more technical
than my family, what
you're going to have by the end
of this section is you are
going to understand how our
plugins, our platform, can
drive traffic to your site,
how it make sure that that
traffic, those people, when
they get to your site, are
more engaged.
I'm going to talk to you about
how you can increase the
clickthrough rate, how many
people click on your links in
Search, your links in the
stream, by modifying the
snippets to your pages.
I'm hopefully going to tell you
how you can increase the
amount of times your content
is reshared on Google+.
Small secret, cat pictures.
Now the Google+ platform is
made up of a lot of tools.
And what you've seen over the
last year is we've been slowly
adding to that toolbox.
In this session, I'm going to
basically give you a broad
overview and then point you to
other sessions that are going
to be much deeper, much more
detailed, about these tools
and how you can use them.
Now when I first started putting
together these slides,
I was going to give you lots
of examples based on the
well-known site, example.com.
However, Google+ is a
social [INAUDIBLE].
It's social.
Social is about people and the
connections between them.
So it seems a bit weird
to have an abstract
example like that.
So I switched to my own site.
It's a superb little website.
Now the problem with anybody who
builds a site is you build
your site and you hope
they will come.
How do they find you?
Well, a little bit of hope, a
little bit of prayer, or this
little site.
You may have of it.
It's called google.com.
Now what happens is somebody
hears of me, perhaps they see
my hat passing in the street.
And they say, who was
that man in the hat?
They type my name into Search
and they get the classic
Google Search results.
Now for those of you who don't
know what a snippet is, it's
the little box of text that
appears below the link.
This is how Google is telling
you this page, this link, is
about this.
This is what the person who is
searching is going to use to
make their decision.
Now google.com is fantastic.
And we asked ourselves, how
can we improve on that?
How do you upgrade
that experience?
Well the way you upgrade
the experience of using
google.com, the way you give
users better results, more
relevant results, the way you
give publishers more traffic,
more engagement, is you give
publishers more control over
their search results.
You give them more power
to control the snippet.
This is the snippet that turns
up for my own website,
oshineye.com.
It's fantastic.
But as you'll see, the same
snippet appears in the web
search results and in
the Google+ stream.
It shows my face, it shows my
name, it shows a catchy little
phrase I came up with
a long time ago.
The way we give people like
you and me control of the
snippet is with a technology
called schema.org.
Who here has not heard
of schema.org?
OK, great, this is for you.
Schema.org is a community driven
project where Google,
Bing, Yahoo, Yandex, and the
community got together and
said, what if we could markup
web pages in a way that showed
you the entities inside the
pages, that took us from a web
of pages with text in them to
a web of entities where you
understood that a page was about
a person, or a place, or
a review, or a recipe?
And if you could do that in some
way that didn't involve
breaking the web, that didn't
involve rewriting the web.
So you want some method where
you can embed a few extra
invisible attributes into your
web page and now search
engines and other tools can know
what the page is about.
They don't have to
guess anymore.
When we talk about an entity,
which can be a person, a
place, a review, and it's an
extensible ontology, so you
can add many, many more entity
types, it's four basic things.
The type, is it a person, is
it a place, is it a review?
The name, obviously, if it's a
person, the name is the name.
If it's a book, it's a title.
An image, so for me, of course,
it's a photo of me.
And, of course, you
get a description.
So those are the four things you
need to describe an entity
within Google.
Now we've already been doing
a lot of work in web search
around rich snippets.
And we extended the rich
snippets testing tool to also
support schema.org.
And what this means is you can
point a URL in there and we'll
show you, not just the rich
snippets in there, not just
the micro formats, but a
schema.org markup in there,
and show you the entities
in that web page.
The other thing we got when we
spoke to people was they said,
it's not enough just to have
rich snippets testing, I need
help in creating my web
page in the beginning.
So we built this snippet
config tool.
As you can see, it has a
drop-down where you can pick
the most common entity types,
put in your title or name, the
URL, the description, and we'll
show you what the markup
will look like.
For example, on this rather nice
little website, you can
see this is a web page.
Now as a human, you look at
that and you say this is a
page about a person.
For a search engine,
that's hard.
What you want is some way
to markup the HTML.
So if you look at the red
sections, what I've done is I
basically said that I want to
say this whole page, so from
the body element downwards to
the closing body element, is
about a person.
And that I want to say the
name of the person.
So as you can see, just by
adding those red sections,
I've said this page is
about an entity.
I've said the description of
the entity, I've given the
image, and now you know what
the page is about.
So now I have a website.
Google and other search
engines know what
this website is about.
And it's rather cool.
But how are people going
to connect to this?
They go to the website
and they say,
well nothing's changed.
They go back and nothing's
changed.
What you need is a mechanism
where they can choose to
follow a Google+ page, perhaps,
and be notified when
new things happen.
So with Google+ pages, you can
create a connection with
people who visit your website,
and use that to tell them when
interesting things happen.
Here's an example of something
me and some friends built.
It's about Developer
Experience.
Who here has heard of Developer
Experience?
Excellent, our marketing
campaign is working
brilliantly.
It's just me and a couple of
friends, so we don't exactly
have a massive budget.
We do have a Google+
page, however.
And on that, we post links to
the new articles we write, we
post links to events
we attend.
Whenever one of us writes
something interesting about
Developer Experience,
we put links here.
And as you can see, we've got
a pretty big following for
something done by three people
in their spare time.
And the beauty of this is that
this is something that lets
those people know when we do
something new and interesting.
Now the thing about Google+
pages is that for me and my
two friends, who you may have
heard of, Pamela Fox, Michael
Mahemoff, we all want to manage
the page, but we don't
want to share a password.
So Google+ lets multiple
people manage one page.
At the same time, Google+
lets one person
manage multiple pages.
As you can see there, I
have one, two, three,
four Google+ pages.
The last one is particularly
funny.
Who here has a Google+ page?
Keep your hands up.
OK, who here has two?
Four?
Six?
Who has five?
Gerwin wins.
So the nice thing about Google+
is you can create
many, many pages for
interesting things,
interesting concepts, brands,
books, your blog, whatever.
And you can use this to build a
community around that idea.
So we have a community around
Developer Experience.
There's a much smaller community
around my book, it's
really good.
There's an incredibly small
community around my blog.
And of course, there's my You've
Never Heard Of Google+
page, which is where I make
mocking comments about my
colleagues when they've never
heard of Richard Dawkins or
Neil Gaiman and I post a
link so they can learn.
Speaking of my colleagues, if
you want to learn more about
how you connect with the people
who visit your page,
your website, you realize
something pretty important.
The best way to connect with
people is face to face or, as
we say, face to face to face.
And if you're interested in
that, you should go to
Jonathan Beri's talk this
afternoon at 1:30 where he'll
tell you about Hangouts, Hangout
applications, and the
power of the Hangout button as
a way to connect with people
who visit your web page.
And of course, and those of you
at home will miss this, if
you want to know who Jonathan
Beri is, he's over there.
So you can see his face.
At this point, I have a website,
people can find it in
Search, they can choose to
stay informed about it by
following it on Google+.
But how do they discover
I have a Google+ page?
Well, the way we do that
is quite simple.
We have something we call
the Google+ badge.
And what this does is gives you
a little snippet of code
that you could put on your
website and people can choose
to use that to follow
your page.
Now here's where it
gets interesting.
You spend a lot of time and
effort getting these people to
come to your site.
The last thing you want
is a badge that takes
them off your site.
So what you'll see in our badge
is that the user can
follow your Google+ page without
leaving your website.
This is pretty cool.
The general principles behind
the badge and the way we want
you to use it is the idea that
you want to keep the people on
your website.
You want them to say,
this page is cool.
You want to [INAUDIBLE]
who thinks your page is cool, so
you could put little faces
at the bottom of the badge.
For everything we're doing in
Google+, everything Julie's
team is building, we've been
building these config tools.
The idea is that whilst we could
have given you a long
complicated manual telling you
how to write correct code, it
would be better to give you a
config tool where you pick the
options you want and we say,
here's the code, now cut and
paste it into your website.
Those of you who have been
following along with our
adventures in Developer
Experience will know that
that's one of our principles.
So as you can see here, you can
basically say, I want to
create a Google+ badge for
Developer Experience.
In a recent change we made last
week, one of many changes
we make, we changed
the drop-down.
So that now when you go there,
because we know who you are,
we just say, well here
are your pages.
It's a small optimization, but
it's the kind of thing we've
been trying to do, trying to
say, what if we make people
the heart of this?
Well, we wouldn't ask a person,
please go off and find
a list of your pages and then
type the number in here.
If we already know this, we
can make this experience
simpler, easier, better.
So you pick your page.
We generate the code for you.
You'd say how wide
you want it.
For those of you who like the
Blues Brothers, we have both
kinds of Google+ badges here.
We have badges for people.
So that's the badge for Jenny
Murphy, one of my colleagues.
And we have badges for, in that
case, it looks like the
Google+ developers'
Google+ page.
As you can see, that's got
54,000 +1's so far.
But from that page, you can
configure badges for you,
badges for your website,
and then you cut
and paste the code.
Speaking of the code, we'll
get to that in a moment.
But first, you can configure the
size, you can choose the
faces that turn up.
This is what it looks on my
website where, as you can see,
I'm plugging my book.
Please buy my book, it's
available for free.
This is what the code
looks like.
As you can see, there's
not a lot of code.
What you do is you take this
chunk of code, you put it into
the head of your document.
And for those of you who are
good at JavaScript, you'll see
that what we're doing is we're,
in lining your web
page, we are creating a script
tag which is going to be
loaded, and then that script tag
is going to asynchronously
walk your DOM and then find this
G+ tag, and then replace
it with the badge.
So this means you can control
where the badge will appear in
your website, which means it
can fit in with whatever
you've already got.
You get a choice of
width, the theme.
We've got a light version,
a dark version.
And of course, we have a
rel="publisher" indication
which is how we tell that this
website owns this Google+
page, because there's
a bidirectional
link between them.
So at this point, I have
a rather nice website.
People can find it, they can
click on the badge, follow the
Google+ page for it, and
they can keep you
informed about changes.
But how do they tell other
people that it's cool?
How do they tell other
people that the
articles in it are cool?
Well, last March, we put
out the +1 button.
This came about because we've
seen that people trust
recommendations from
other people.
They know whose taste
they can trust.
They know, for example, that
if I recommend a camera to
you, it'll almost certainly come
from, it will probably be
something like this.
It will be large, and
heavy, and hurt your
hands after a while.
However, if somebody else
recommends a camera to you, it
may be smaller, it may
be a phone camera.
But you know the people and
you can act accordingly.
When people buy things like
cameras or cars, they want
recommendations from
people they trust.
But the time you're buying the
device and the time the person
is looking for the
recommendation are separate.
With the +1 button, we bring
those two things together, so
that whilst you're doing your
initial research, you +1 the
things that you think
are good.
Then when other people who know
you or who are following
you on Google+ are searching for
similar things, we'll show
you the recommendation, the
endorsement, you gave to that.
You can, of course, always +1
then hit Share if you want to
tell people immediately, I found
a great camera shop.
The +1 button has a config tool,
like everything else
we're doing.
As you can see, you can control
the width, you can
specify if you want it to load
asynchronously or not, you can
choose if you want the markup
to be HTML5 valid or not.
Thanks to Gerwin for
spotting that one.
This is what it looks
like on my website.
As you can see, you +1 the
snippet we talked about
earlier turns up there, you
choose the circles you want to
see it, you can have a little
section of faces.
The code is going to seem
very, very familiar.
It's the same snippet you've
seen before, which is going to
be put into your web page.
The code is going to be
asynchronously loaded, it's
going to walk the DOM because
it's going to be looking for
this G+ tag.
As you can see, you
can control the
formatting of the +1 button.
But that's going to be
replaced with the
code for the +1 button.
So I've got a great site.
People are coming to it.
They're choosing to follow the
page associated with it, so I
can tell them about
cool new things.
They've got a +1 button, so
they can tell other people
this is a great website.
Now imagine my website had,
I don't know, something
controversial, like perhaps an
article comparing Nikon versus
Canon or an article saying that
maybe hats are awesome
and you should really
be wearing a hat.
And you want to tell people
about this, but you don't want
to +1 this.
You don't want people to think
that you're pro hats or
perhaps you've chosen
Nikon over Canon.
But you want to tell people,
look at this
guy, he's so wrong.
So we need a way to share
without endorsing.
So we put together
the Share button.
Like everything else we do,
it has a config tool.
This may sound familiar.
You can control a variety of
things about the feeling,
whether it's HTML5
valid or not.
It looks very similar
to the +1 button.
We're building a set of tools
that are internally consistent
that reuse aspects of each
other so that if you
understand part of the system,
you can use that understanding
to learn the rest.
The code, tell me if this sounds
familiar, there's a bit
of JavaScript, which is going to
be put into your web page,
it's going to get loaded, it's
going to asynchronously walk
the DOM And then, it's
going to find a G+
tag and replace it.
As you can see, you can always
hard code a Share button to
talk about a particular URL.
But by default, it will load
or point to the current
website, the current page.
You may remember this gentleman
from last year.
This is Timothy Jordan.
If you want to learn more
about how you can do
interesting things with the
Google+ button with other
aspects of Google+, if you want
to learn, for instance,
how yo can use the JavaScript
call back in the +1 button to
use with analytics tools or
other things, you should
attend Timothy's talk tomorrow
at 2:45 where he'll go into
how you can get more
with Google+.
Now my website, I like to think
that my website isn't so
much HTML5 as HTML3.2.
It's very simple, I'm
a simple person.
But imagine a world where I
wasn't a simple person and I
had a website and it was latency
sensitive or it was
written in Flash.
And I was the kind of person who
was good enough at design
that I wanted control of every
single pixel on my website.
Well I can't use the
existing buttons
because I give up control.
So what you need is
something else.
What we've built for you is a
little thing we called URL
Share Endpoint.
Who here has used this?
OK, so this is cool.
Basically we have that
special URL.
It takes two parameters, HL for
language and a URL parameter.
So what this does is you say,
give me a share box pointing
to that URL.
And that's just a link.
And you can basically put
any image you want in
front of that link.
And because it's just
a link, nothing
gets loaded from Google.
Well, it's just a link,
so it's instant.
There's no worries
about latency
because it's just a link.
It'll fit into your Flash
website with no problems
whatsoever.
We give you an icon if you
want to use our icon.
You can, of course,
use your own.
You can choose to serve the icon
from us or from your own
website if you're particularly
sensitive about latency.
But what we noticed with a lot
of people, they would just
write in this code.
They just wanted a button with
a graphic served from Google,
might as well save costs, and
when you clicked on it, it
popped up in a new window and
it had a share box in it.
So we said, if everybody's doing
the same thing, perhaps
we should just give
them the code.
So we did.
This is what we call
the URL Share Link.
If you're interested in what
we've done when you start
taking this idea that you could
have URLs that perform
actions, if you can start
thinking about what happens
when multiple sites have these
kinds of endpoints and you
could do server to server
integration, you should go to
Paul Kinlan's talk tomorrow at
11:45 where he'll talk to you
about Web Intents and how things
like our URL Share Link
play a part in that.
If you're interested in how all
of these buttons load so
quickly at the scale we are, if
you think about it, we have
billions of impressions a
day, how do we do that?
How do we make that fast?
You should go and see John and
Malte who are talking at 5:15
and they'll tell you exactly
how we do this.
Now I don't want to give
you the impression that
we only do the web.
As you saw in Vic's talk this
morning, we've crossed the
point where we have more mobile
traffic, more mobile
usage, than web usage.
So if you go to tomorrow's
talk at 1:30, Julia and
Francis will tell you
interesting things about
Android and iOS development
for Google+.
You should really go there.
But that's not all.
Let's go back to my family
for the moment.
We talked about all the
things you can do
with the Google+ platform.
But they're not technical, so
most of these details would
have gone over their heads.
And they would say, hold on,
explain this to me in the
context of a real world shop.
Pick something real, don't
make something up, not
abstract, concrete.
And I'd say, well,
this is Le Monde.
They're where I got
this hat from.
Beautiful shop run by a little
old couple, and as you can see
from the review, I
love the shop.
I go there once a year
and I buy a vintage
hat and I buy a suit.
But I only go there once
a year, so if anything
interesting happens at
that shop during that
year, I miss it.
If they have a sale,
I miss it.
They're not the kind of people
who are going to
run a mailing list.
They want something simple, easy
to understand, easy to
use, where Google does the
heavy lifting for them.
And because they're an old
fashioned kind of shop--
I mean, they sell vintage
outfits--
they want something simple.
So they also think of their
metrics very differently to
developers.
They're not thinking in terms
of increasing traffic and
increasing engagement.
They're thinking in terms of how
do we get more customers
through the door of our shop?
How do we get more business,
so that when the customer
comes in, they come back?
How they do that?
How do they go to a world
where you've got more
customers who are happier and,
thus, more business?
And how do they go from people
that come into their shop
regularly to a community
of people?
Well this is why we
did Google+ Local.
Now this is still in
a very early form.
And we have a small number of
trusted testers who have got
the fully integrated
experience.
But what those people get is
a Google+ page for their
particular shop, their
particular business.
And you can follow that page and
you can see who else likes
to follow that page and you can
engage in discussions with
the page and with the
other people.
And you can discover that you
have things in common.
You can connect those other
people, in my case, around my
love of hats.
Now I'm going to finish up.
And I'm going to finish
up with two quotes.
One is from Leo Rosten.
You probably have never
heard of him Anybody
heard of Leo Rosten?
OK, anybody heard of
Margaret Mead?
Hooray .
So he's her brother-in-law.
He also wrote lots of books,
but that's his
biggest claim to fame.
And one of the things he talks
about is this idea about why
do we share.
At Google+ we believe it's
important to share the right
things with the right people.
It should be controlled
sharing.
And that's because you want
to be in control of who
understands you.
You want to choose who you
want to have a better
understanding of.
You want to choose
your community.
So if you're a Google+ page,
you're building a community,
you want to have some
control over that.
But in the wider context of
Google, in the wider context
of the world where we're
thinking about upgrading the
Google experience, I want to
finish with this quote from
Clay Shirky.
And he talks about how important
it is to connect
with other people, not just
with information.
So when we talk about Google
and our mission to give
everybody access to information,
we've got to
think beyond and above.
And we've got to start saying,
how do we upgrade Google?
How do we upgrade the Google
experience so that it's about
connecting and sharing
with people?
And that includes, of
course, my family.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
So I think we have a few
minutes for questions.
Does anybody have
any questions?
If so, please use the
microphones there and there.
I'll try to repeat them
for the people
watching the live stream.
Oh, and by the way,
hello, London.
Any questions?
Oh, we have one question
at the back.
AUDIENCE: Yes, hi.
How do you see the development
of Google+ for enterprises?
There's a lot of businesses that
have gone up into Google
Apps and those businesses are
getting bigger and bigger.
And most of my customers, we
do implement Google Apps.
I'm asking, now we need a sort
of Google+ environment, but
for the company.
I mean social, but
ADE OSHINEYE: So the question
was, how do we see the
development of Google+
for the enterprise?
When we built Google+, we
started with the enterprise we
know best, Google.
We have 30,000 employees,
maybe more nowadays.
And we have a Google+ instance
we run for ourselves.
We put out Google+ for
enterprise a few months ago
and it's seen incredible uptake,
as companies have
realized that they can actually
bring the benefits of
Google+ within their company.
They can connect people within
the company to each other
around things beyond just
the department.
And all the features we're
rolling out here, those are
also rolling out for
enterprises.
And I think you're going to be
pleasantly surprised as we
keep working and adding
new features.
I think we're up to about
a feature a day now?
JULIE FARAGO: I think about
a feature a day.
That's right.
ADE OSHINEYE: And most of those
features are rolling out
to Enterprise as well.
Obviously, there are more
complications for Enterprise.
But given that I have 30,000
people who know where I sit,
who want these features, I think
you'll be seeing many
more Enterprise features rolling
out for Google+ as
time goes on.
I believe there was a gentleman
there with a question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I have
a curiosity.
At the beginning you showed us
how to create the snippets so
we can see our picture
or something, and the
description, in the
search results.
How long does it take for Google
to recognize that my
website has those snippets?
ADE OSHINEYE: So the question
was, how long does it take for
Google to recognize that my
site has a new snippet?
AUDIENCE: Is it real time?
Or does it need to wait?
I don't know.
ADE OSHINEYE: So what
we have in Google
is we have a crawler.
And it crawls your site based on
a lot of signals including
things like, do you a site map,
how often does your site
change, things like that.
So it's not guaranteed.
There are things you can do
within Webmaster Tools that
can accelerate the time it'll
be crawled, but it's not
guaranteed.
If you look on the rich
snippet site, there's
information about things like
Webmaster Tools and site maps
and how you can use those to
accelerate your recrawl rate.
But that's all we can
really tell you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JULIE FARAGO: I will say that
if you do use rich snippets,
then as soon as people start
sharing or +1ing from your
site, then that will immediately
work with Google+.
So that is real time
guaranteed.
AUDIENCE: We created a
Google+ Local page.
ADE OSHINEYE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: It got migrated
over for us.
And the ability to maintain
hours there is helpful.
One of the things I was
wondering is, is there an
ability to automatically push
and update the hours for that
page from somewhere?
Is there a writable API
for that purpose?
Because we don't want to have to
maintain the hours in five
different web pages and
a couple of different
applications.
We would like to be able
to push in one spot
and then get it pulled.
ADE OSHINEYE: So the question
is, if I have a Google+ Local
page, is there a programmatic
way to update the opening
hours for that page?
AUDIENCE: Correct.
ADE OSHINEYE: So when we
announced Google+ Local, we
said that it was part of a
migration of the 80 million
place pages into Google+.
And that as part of that, we
would start adding other
features you were used to in
Place pages as time goes on.
So I think that's your answer.
We're going to give you a lot
of the functionality you've
seen in Place pages.
Remember, the goal is
to upgrade Google.
So that includes things
like Place pages.
And that is coming, but
I can't tell you when.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ADE OSHINEYE: I think we have
a question in the back.
AUDIENCE: My question is about
how different types of content
perform on Google.
A lot of focus is on
events and photos.
My specific question is about
the video experience, sharing
video content from different
sites and popular shows, et
cetera, et cetera, if
there's any plans.
ADE OSHINEYE: Do you
want to take this?
JULIE FARAGO: I can tell
you anecdotally.
ADE OSHINEYE: You should
probably repeat the question
for [INAUDIBLE].
JULIE FARAGO: Ah, sorry,
thank you.
So the question was about how
different content performs on
Google+ in terms
of engagement.
What we've seen is that
multimedia content does
particularly well.
So videos, images, links with
photos associated with them,
are the ones that get
the most engagement.
So if you can make the visual
representation in the stream
engaging, then it is much more
likely to get higher levels of
engagement from the users.
ADE OSHINEYE: I will
add one thing.
Gerwin, who's sitting in front
here, built a tool that
actually shows you what times
you should post to reach the
most members of the audience.
It's really cool and he built
it on top of the API.
If there are no more questions,
then I think we
should all go to lunch.
Thank you very much.
You've been wonderful.